ضباب دخاني بلاستيكي هكذا يصف الباحثون
تريليونات الجسيمات البلاستيكيه التي
تتدفق الى المحيطات وتزن نحو مليونين
واربعمائه الف طن متري
وتتضاعف كل ست سنوات تقريبا دراسه اجراها
فريق من الباحثين الدوليين ونشرت في مجله
بلوس 1 العلميه المتخصصه تعتمد على ما
يقرب من اثنتي عشره الف عينه جمعت على
مدار اربعين عاما من جميع احواض المحيطات
الرئيسيه في العالم
بدءا من عام 2004 لاحظ الباحثون ارتفاعا
كبيرا في تلك المواد البلاستيكيه تزامنا
مع ارتفاع هائل في انتاج البلاستيك
مستويات غير مسبوقه للتلوث البلاستيكي
شهدتها محيطات العالم خلال الخمسه عشر
عاما الماضيه وقد تشكل صدمه لمحادثات
الامم المتحده للحد من التلوث البلاستيكي
التي بدات العام الماضي سافر الباحثون الى
محيطات العالم جميعها لجمع العينات
ولاحظوا ان عشره في المئه فقط من
البلاستيك اعيد تدويره وان المواد التي لا
تصل الى مدافن النفايات يمكن ان تجتاح
الانهار او ان تنتهي مباشره في المحيطات
ركز الباحثون على احواض شمال المحيط
الاطلسي وشمال المحيط الهادئ وذلك لان تلك
الاحواض خضعت للدراسه بشكل متكرر على مدى
عقود حيث تقطن النسبه الاكبر من سكان
العالم لكن ذلك لا ينفي حقيقه العثور على
تركيزات عاليه من البلاستيك في كل مكان
يلفتون شطاء مكافحه التلوث الى ان التعامل
مع البلاستيك قبل دخوله المجاري المائيه
اسهل بكثير من تنظيفه بعد ذلك ويعول هؤلاء
النشطاء الى جانب المفاوضين الدوليين على
استكمال معاهده البلاستيك بحلول عام 2024
التي ستحاول تنظيم جميع جوانب دوره حياه
البلاستيك بما فيها انواع المواد
الكيميائيه التي تدخل فيه وما اذا كان من
السهل اعاده تدويرها يوضح العلماء ان
المواد البلاستيكيه الموجوده في المحيطات
تتحلل ببطء الى قطع اصغر معروفه باسم
اللدائن الدقيقه يقل طولها عن خمسه
ملليمترات ويمكن ان تاكلها الحيوانات
البحريه كما ان تلك اللدائن عثر عليها في
مجرى الدم البشري الام الذي يطرح تساؤلات
عده بشان مخاطر تلك اللدائن على صحه
الانسان وكيف يستطيع الجسم التخلص منها
وهل من الممكن ان تتراكم او تبقى حبيسه في
اعضاء معينه دون غيرها